[Música]
a
escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 dedicado hoy a la política francesa
arranca la nueva legislatura con una
asamblea nacional muy fragmentada y con
el partido del presidente emmanuel
mccomb sin mayoría absoluta en un país
francia poco acostumbrado a gobernar con
alianzas y de todo ello hablamos con la
responsable del partido de mack como en
el distrito 15 de parís barbara granate
lee y barbara muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros muchísimas gracias a
ustedes por siguen bueno barbara ustedes
franco-argentina y está en el partido
del presidente desde los inicios desde
el 2017 ahora empieza la decimosexta
legislatura con una asamblea nacional
muy fragmentada en la que su partido no
tiene mayoría absoluta esto quiere decir
que para aprobar leyes va a tener que
buscar
alianzas con diputados de otros países
de otros partidos en el mandato de
macrón parece ser que va a ser muy
complicado con qué partido de la
posición va a pactar el presidente creo
que no se trata de con qué partido va a
tener que gobernar sino con quienes va a
tener que gobernar eso es lo más
importante hoy en día la realidad es que
el partido de macrón tiene una mayoría
es una mayoría que no es absoluta
entonces faltan algunos votos faltan 20
y pico 30 votos esos votos va a haber
que ir a buscarlos no necesariamente
todos juntos al mismo partido pero ir
después diputado por diputado viendo
también quiénes son los que quieren
contribuir a que francia avance a que
puedan pasar leyes aprobarse leyes que
vayan digamos en que digamos que
favorezcan a los franceses creo que lo
más importante acá es que los franceses
en las elecciones que pasaron nos
pidieron que cambiemos el método que
teníamos que gobernar amos de otra
manera vamos a tener que seguir algo que
nosotros ya conocíamos que hacemos desde
el principio que es dialogar que es ir
debatir tratar de confrontar ideas y de
avanzar en tal vez ideológicamente haya
un partido que sea más cercano son los
republicanos el partido conservador del
ex presidente de nicolás
pero esto ya ha dicho este partido que
bueno que no piensan ser la rueda de
repuesto
piensa que este mandato de macrón va a
correr el cursor más a la derecha para
justamente conseguir esos apoyos de los
diputados más conservadores no lo creo
creo que desde el principio el partido
de makro ha sido un partido que no era
ni de derecha ni de izquierda creo que
no vamos a cambiar nuestro
posicionamiento político vamos a seguir
siendo ni de derecha ni de izquierda
vamos a ir a buscar a aquellos de
derechas que se identifiquen quizás que
sea más de centroderecha que se
identifiquen con las políticas y con el
programa de manuel macro y también
aquellos de izquierdas que sean
republicanos y que quieran contribuir
también a reformar lo lo que hay que
reformar y hacer pasar las leyes que
hagan falta la alianza de izquierdas
nubes que engloba varios partidos desde
el partido comunista ecologistas
socialistas
y la gracia y sumisa de mellon son tiene
131 diputados y la extrema derecha de
marine le pen tiene 89 quien es el
principal partido de la oposición según
usted
lamentablemente es el
racionalismo nacional es la agrupación
nacional porque porque son un partido en
la nubes es una agrupación de partidos
son muchos partidos juntos que de hecho
no se pusieron de acuerdo tienen cuatro
grupos distintos en la asamblea nacional
entonces lamentablemente es la extrema
derecha que es la principal fuerza
opositora habido varios miembros del
gobierno que han hecho comentarios un
tanto ambiguos y algunos bueno incluso
bastante directos no que parece que
normalicen la extrema derecha es
bastante histórico lo que han conseguido
en la asamblea nacional
pienso por ejemplo en el ministro de
justicia víctor moretti que en una
entrevista abocaba la posibilidad de
avanzar con el partido de madryn de penn
o la diputada ma cronista se link alves
que dijo cuando necesitamos una mayoría
y si es bueno para los franceses iremos
a buscar esos votos refiriéndose a la
extrema derecha macrón va a aliarse con
la extrema derecha
desde ya por supuesto que no hay ningún
tipo de alianza con la extrema derecha
no hay ningún valor que nos que nos una
creo que lo hemos visto a lo largo de
todo el icann que de todos estos 5 años
todos nos oponen a la extrema derecha no
haber ningún tipo de alianza después
obviamente si los diputados de extrema
derecha quieren votar propuestas que
hagamos libre cada uno de votar lo que
lo que quiera pero por supuesto no va a
haber una alianza con extrema derecha se
puede poner el mismo saco como algunos
han hecho a la nubes la coalición de
izquierdas y a la extrema derecha
a ver
hay muchos y creo que también hay que
entender esa esa visión que ven en las
nubes hay
una parte de la izquierda y también hay
una extrema izquierda no hay que
olvidarse que el effie es un partido de
extrema izquierda para muchos entonces
es entendible que mucha gente muchos
diputados no quieran tampoco aliarse con
la extrema derecha ni con la extrema
izquierda volviendo a los resultados del
19 de junio en los que su partido el
partido del presidente no consigue la
mayoría absoluta usted que ha estado en
el terreno haciendo campaña tanto en las
presidenciales como en las legislativas
que ha fallado porque no renovaron tanta
confianza a ver yo creo que es muy
difícil para un militante decir lo que
ha fallado creo que primero y principal
y a veces eso se olvida hoy en día hoy
estamos todo el tiempo hablando del
fracaso de manuel macro de todo lo que
fue mal creo que lo más importante
también es que pasó algo histórico que
es reelegir un presidente en francia
cinco habitaciones eso es algo que nunca
antes había sucedido enmanuel macrón fue
reelecto de hecho en la primera vuelta
sacó incluso un poco más alto que en el
2017 entonces es primero y principal
creo que tenemos que poner eso a la
balanza después obviamente también vemos
que hay un descontento importante y tú
lo decías así hace un rato el hecho de
que la agrupación nacional el partido de
marín lepén esté en la asamblea con 89
diputados por supuesto es un fracaso
creo que para la sociedad francesa en su
conjunto que afa que en que hemos hecho
creo que de algún modo vamos a tener que
ver como en los próximos cinco años
tratar de evitar esta fragmentación de
la sociedad y tratar de evitar
justamente esta este crecimiento de los
de los extremos en qué medida el partido
de macrón o algunos candidatos del macro
nismo son culpables de ese ascenso la
asamblea de la extrema derecha porque
hubo duelos en la segunda vuelta creo
que unos 60 circunscripciones
rivales nubes extrema derecha y los
candidatos macro nistas que habían sido
eliminados no fueron muy claros a la
hora de decir bueno hay que hacer frente
a la extrema derecha y votar a la
izquierda en qué medida su partido es
responsable de esa subida a ver creo que
creo que no es una cuestión de
responsabilidad en el partido de macrón
creo que él son los franceses los que
fueron libres de votar por el candidato
y el diputado que creían conveniente
una vez más digamos lo que podemos hacer
si es una especie de mea culpa de decir
durante estos cinco años hay gente que
se opone a la política de macrón y creo
que más allá de decir esa gente quería
que marine lepén o su partido estuviera
en la asamblea creo que era simplemente
también expresar un descontento con
emanuel macro y bueno en ese sentido
creo que podemos tener sí una cuota de
responsabilidad si se quiere pero pero
no más allá nada no sabes la reforma
principal de esta legislatura o una de
las principales es la de las
jubilaciones
que ya quería hacerla en la primera en
el primer quinquenio
macro me quiere retrasar a la de
jubilación de los 62 a los 65 años
y esto va a ser un poco bastante tenso
porque va a necesitar votos de otros
partidos y si vemos la extrema derecha
no quiere que se retrase la de
jubilación y tampoco la izquierda
desde el oficialismo como piensan sacar
adelante esta ley a ver por un lado creo
que
hay mucho
hay mucha mentira que alrededor
del tema jubilatorio porque la realidad
es que hoy en día es necesario trabajar
más si queremos tener el sistema social
que tenemos si queremos seguir cada vez
vivimos más entonces también si queremos
tener ese sistema viviendo más sí o sí
hay que trabajar más la realidad que
muchos de esos que proponen la
jubilación a 60 a los 60 años no dicen
que de todos modos ellos no tocan al
hecho de cotizar durante 40 años
entonces hoy en día quiénes son los
franceses que se jubilan verdaderamente
a los 62 hoy en día ya hay mucha gente
que comenzó a trabajar un poco más tarde
y que de todos modos se jubila más tarde
entonces creo que hay una cosa de la de
la reforma de la jubilación de manuel
macrón que es importante y es el hecho
de decir
a lo que se llama la peni bilidad las
carreras largas todo eso la oposición
muchas veces nos acusa de no tenerlo en
cuenta y sin embargo eso es uno de los
pilares de la reforma la idea no es que
todo el mundo se jubila a los 65 años la
idea es que los que tienen digamos
empleos más
de oficina que gente que puede trabajar
que tienen una esperanza de vida de
hecho mayor por ejemplo a la de un
obrero que esa gente pueda trabajar más
ahora obviamente el que empezó a
trabajar a los 20 años 19 años que se
pueda jubilar antes a todos esos que
trabajan en
oficios temibles que puedan jubilarse
antes eso sí porque hay que recordar que
para tener una pensión completa son 40
años trabajados en francia y otros
países que es menor bueno otra de las
leyes importantes y que se va a debatir
en los próximos días es la del poder
adquisitivo en esta ley hay supresión de
impuestos por ejemplo está la supresión
del impuesto de la televisión con el que
se financia esta casa y otros medios
públicos franceses
hay mucha preocupación porque no está
muy claro de dónde va a salir la partida
para financiar
los medios públicos por ejemplo y si con
este cambio de que no haya ese impuesto
se va a perder independencia a la hora
de informarnos eso nos puede aclarar un
poco este tema y creo que a ver
creo que más allá de donde venga de qué
con qué tasa en particular se pague
obviamente todas las cosas que
subvenciona el estado son los franceses
los que lo pagan entonces
poco importa de donde venga eso de todos
modos es el contribuyente francés el que
está detrás y el que está contribuyendo
a eso ahora porque se supere porque
suprimimos es a esa tasa audiovisual
porque se pueden hacer ese dinero puede
salir de otros lugares entonces la idea
también hoy en día es que el francés
tenga un poder adquisitivo mayor es algo
que
emanuel macrón se comprometió a hacer en
2017 que ha hecho durante todo este
quinquenio porque digamos bajaron los
impuestos se bajaron digamos no sólo
para las familias pero también para las
empresas entonces creo que esto es algo
muy importante es un compromiso de
campaña es un compromiso una promesa que
ha sido
respetada en este quinquenio y que vamos
a llevar adelante para el próximo
quinquenio hacer por ejemplo sé
si se adoptó la revalorización también
de los salarios de los empleados
públicos hay un montón de medidas que se
están poniendo en marcha también por
ejemplo lo que se llama el bucle tarifas
o sea el congelamiento de las tarifas de
la electricidad del gas cosas que hacen
que por ejemplo cuando comparamos con
otros países europeos en francia tenemos
un aumento del 4% mientras que en otros
lugares puede haber sido del 45 200 100
por ciento más y ya para terminar
tenemos muy poco tiempo en unos segundos
desde el macro mismo se plantea la
posibilidad de convocar elecciones
anticipadas entonces creo que la idea no
es hoy en día disolver la asamblea si
vemos que efectivamente hay un bloqueo
puede que sea una opción pero claramente
no es la opción actual barbara granate
lee muchísimas gracias por todas estas
precisiones muchísimas gracias a ustedes
y gracias a todos ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que nos pueden
seguir también en internet nrf y
mundo.com bien france24 puntocom hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]